So we're waiting to see who will be in Joe
Biden's cabinet.
And there have been a variety of different
names floated.
Some have been denied, some have not been
denied.
It's very interesting to look at the way that
all goes.
And ultimately, we're going to know and we'll
do a deep dove about Joe Biden's cabinet.
But as is often the case as a precursor to
selecting your cabinet, Joe Biden has selected
his chief of staff.
This is his first major staff pick, of course,
the vice president, Kamala Harris, and a very
important selection which was made some time
ago.
But for post-election, this is really good
news.
Ronald Klain is going to be Joe Biden's chief
of staff.
It's just a great choice.
And everybody from Alexandria, Cassio Cortez
to centrist Democrats to Democratic consultants,
everybody says this is a fantastic choice.
And I'm going to tell you a little bit about
Ronald Klain.
But when the bar is not not that Klain isn't
a good choice no matter what, but when the
bar is so low already because of Donald Trump,
Ronald Klain is an adult who is not only intelligent,
but he's organized and he gets things done.
That's already going to be much better than
the people that Donald Trump has had as chiefs
of staff.
Ronald Klain also happened to be Barack Obama's
Ebola czar during the Obama Biden administration.
And if we want to talk about signals when
Joe Biden selects Ronald Klain, it's a signal
that he rejects the chaos of the Trump administration.
He rejects the idea of these wild, loose cannon,
unhinged staffers in a lot of different positions.
I'm going to be very upfront.
Ronald Klain is going to be a boring chief
of staff.
He's going to be a sensible, sober chief of
staff.
You're not likely to hear a lot from Ronald
Klain in terms of cartoonish incidents and
scandals and fiascos.
And if you're dealing with a pandemic, as
Joe Biden is going to be, and unfortunately,
because Donald Trump is just done with coronavirus,
a very serious pandemic on January 20th, Ronald
Klain is also particularly qualified because
he has experience dealing with medical outbreaks
already.
He's a lawyer with a solid legal mind.
He has a relatively progressive lean in terms
of what you would expect for a president like
Joe Biden.
And he has the experience that is required
at exactly this time and again, widespread
praise.
AOC tweeting, quote, Good news and an encouraging
choice, anti Trump Republicans, Steve Schmidt,
who's not our friend.
But but the point is, everybody recognizes
Ronald Klain is a good choice.
Steve Schmidt tweeting, Looks like the office
of chief of staff has just been upgraded by
one hundred gazillion percent with the appointment
of Ronald Klain squad member Congresswoman
Ayanna Pressley tweeting, quote, Having a
dedicated, humble, hardworking team around
you is everything.
Congratulations.
Ronald Klain encouraged to see you step into
this role and look forward to working together.
Senator Elizabeth Warren tweeting, Ronald
Klain is a superb choice for chief of staff.
He understands the magnitude of the health
and economic crisis and he has the experience
to lead this next administration through it.
Ron has earned trust all across the entire
Democratic Party.
I think you get it in Washington.
You rarely see such unified and nearly unanimous
reaction to any choice for any position ever,
no matter how qualified the person is.
He was on the ball.
Ronald Klain was in terms of coronavirus.
He wrote back in January, nearly 11 months
ago, a piece in the Atlantic where he said
or the piece was called Coronavirus is Coming
and Trump Isn't Ready.
And he explained the ways in which Donald
Trump was not ready.
So eventually we're going to be doing a deep
dove on Joe Biden's cabinet as it comes together,
expecting some names around Thanksgiving time.
But for now, the person who will be helping
Biden choose the cabinet is as close to.
A perfect selection, as there could be, and
contrast it with Donald Trump's latest chief
of staff, Mark Meadows, who has been running
around Trump rallies with no mask high five
people, Mark Meadows caught coronavirus.
Mark Meadows continue to insist that Donald
Trump would win, even though Donald Trump
lost and said weeks ago, we are not going
to control the pandemic in what was arguably
the most defeatist statement we've heard from
any administration official about the pandemic
since the start.
So change is very much in the air.
I don't expect to agree with every cabinet
choice Joe Biden makes, but so far, this is
exactly what you would want to see.
Now, let me say one other thing.
There have been I've been getting a lot of
emails from from people linking me to articles,
some articles saying Warren and Bernie are
being considered for cabinet positions and
other articles saying Warren and Bernie are
being frozen out of consideration for cabinet
positions.
With so many rumors floating around and so
many cabinet positions and so much else to
talk about, I don't think there's much value
in me commenting on speculation about Biden's
cabinet.
When Biden chooses his cabinet, we will do
a deep dove.
We will analyze every single cabinet member.
Some of you will find it boring.
Some of you will find it valuable.
I think it's very important and we are going
to do that to sort of set up our understanding
of the Biden administration as it comes in.
One of the things I think is important to
think about is that when you select Democratic
senators to your cabinet, their Senate seats
open.
Different states have different rules about
who and how gets to decide on their replacement.
Here in Massachusetts, we have a Republican
governor currently and as at least as an interim
replacement to Elizabeth Warren until there's
a special election that may mean a Republican
senator replaces Elizabeth Warren in Vermont.
I actually don't know offhand exactly how
it goes.
But while I obviously believe that Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders would be fantastic
cabinet selections, Bernie could be secretary
of Labor.
There's other positions he could do.
Elizabeth Warren could be secretary of education,
treasury secretary.
You know, you could make an argument for either
of them as secretary of commerce.
There's no doubt that these are qualified
people.
I do.
And and I don't pretend to have an answer
to this question.
It is it's not rhetorical.
It's a real question.
Are we better served by keeping Bernie and
Warren, the two most progressive members of
the Senate right now in the Senate?
I think that that's a completely legitimate
question to be asking.
And given that you could pick people that
are arguably as good or almost as good as
them for cabinet positions, although maybe
they would be less recognizable in terms of
name recognition.
Do we gain more by keeping them in the Senate?
I think that almost certainly if Warren and
Bernie leave the Senate to be in Biden's cabinet,
it's a guarantee that the Senate moves to
the right.
When you take the two most liberal members
of the Senate and you replace them with people
that are arguably and almost certainly less
liberal, the average political orientation
of the Senate moves a little bit to the right.
And I think that that's a perfectly legitimate
and important thing to be talking about.
And we will discuss it if Democratic senators
do make it into Biden's cabinet.
We will talk about it if they don't.
And there are complaints, where is Bernie?
Where is Warren?
We will also talk about it completely fundamental
understanding of the reality of what happens
when you take a Democratic senator out.
What happens to that seat of in the immediate
and also in the medium to long term when there
is a special election?
We'll have more about Ronald Klain and Biden's
cabinet on our Instagram page.
Follow us there at David Pakman show.
And listen, if you're already on Instagram,
follow me at David Pakman as well.